[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie so we finally
got our first flash trailer and our
first look at Grant Gustin in action
full-on in action so this is going to be
a breakdown of that as well as an update
about all the new things that we've
learned about the show in the last
couple of weeks my arrow finale video is
going to post later tonight that's going
to be like a whole separate video before
this clip we'd seen a bunch of pictures
from the set of him in costume but it's
really hard to judge when there aren't
any special effects added and they
haven't color corrected any of the
footage so right off the bat most
obvious thing the superpowers I'm
totally digging what they're doing with
them both the look of Grant Gustin at
SuperSpeed and the way that his
character treats his powers in the
comics Barry Allen is not a reluctant
hero so it's not like Bruce Banner and
the Hulk
you know Barry won't treat the Speed
Force like a curse it's a blessing of
all the Justice League a list
superheroes he's one of the most
positive and excitable ones
understandably remember what an arrow
fanboy he was during that crossover
episode earlier this year he's like a
superhero fanboy that got called to the
majors and just couldn't be happier
because he's up racing around in the
suit there's a bit of a disconnect
because right now in the normal timeline
he's still passed out in Central City at
STAR Labs he doesn't know anything about
his new powers and he doesn't have the
suit yet so I'd be willing to bet that
most of the footage from this trailer is
from that pilot episode right now
they're not in production for season 1
yet so the only footage they'd have is
stuff they've already shot or like green
screen pickups that they did on the fly
they don't always include everything
from trailers in the final versions of
episodes but I think we can plan for
Stephen Amell and Felicity to at least
have minor appearances in that first
episode of the flash unless they expand
it and make it a two-parter but let's
talk about arrow crossover because
essentially this trailer is a crossover
the flash will be its own show but Marc
Guggenheim and Andrew Kreisberg and all
the other producers are doing the best
they can to make it a shared universe it
kind of already is a crossover though
whenever you consider episode 19 with
Caitlin snow and Cisco Ramon star lab
stuff that being said I think that the
physical crossovers will be limited to a
couple times the season but there will
be a ton of verbal references to each
other shows
like whenever Felicity says she's been
dumped by someone in a coma you know
talking about Barry and iris West which
actually I don't think is true iris West
is supposed to be Barry Allen's best
friend in the way that Oliver and
Felicity are best friends
you know people that just have a lot of
chemistry together so all you shippers
out there just think of iris and Barry
as the new olicity so next let's talk a
little bit about the story of season one
and remember that Barry works in the
crime lab he's a CSI person his mentor
you know slash father figure is
detective West so there will be like a
freak of the week crime solving aspect
to the show but the big main story will
be Barry learning to use his powers and
clear his father of his mother's murder
remember that big map board in his
office with all the connecting red lines
imagine him superspeeding to all those
different places getting his CSI swerve
on so like the freak of the week aspect
of the show will be like the day-to-day
and the mother's murder will be going on
in the background
it's like era where the team takes down
criminals every week but the main story
has been all about Deathstroke in the
mirakuru as for big Deathstroke level
villains on the show obviously the
Edward Thawne character is the big
question mark obviously I think we're
all expecting him to become zoom it
actually if you look at this little bit
at the end of the trailer it looks like
zoom is just quickly passing through the
credits so I just think it's a professor
zoom teaser so I'm getting really really
excited I'm totally expecting flash to
do the same thing that arrow did with
the superhero names and just shorten
them there are other comic book
characters on the show like Caitlin snow
and Cisco Ramon but instead of being
full-on superheroes they might be doing
a Laurel type thing with them as in
Laurel is the Black Canary in the comics
but on arrow they just made her a normal
person with the promise that in a future
season at some point she'd become the
Black Canary so Caitlin snow could
always turn out to be killer frost or
Frost if we're just shortening it but
don't expect that anytime soon she
seemed like a really fun person in
episode 19 anyway so I'm thinking she's
going to be one of the good guys for
most of season 1 at least keep your eyes
peeled on her though because remember
agents of shield did that thing where
they made agent Ward turn evil at the
end of the season you know become a
Hydra person let's talk about some of
the other characters though I've
actually done videos for a lot of the
main characters already but Tom
Cavanaugh is another new you know pretty
important person he's going to play
Harrison wells that's the character
that's responsible for the particle
accelerator explosion where a bunch of
people died so he's kind of going to be
like the professor Ivo of the show
just hated on he's not gonna be a
villain like Ivo though as for John
Wesley Shipp I think we're obviously all
hoping that he turns out to be the Jay
Garrick flash but there's a couple other
possibilities and his character is going
to be recurring whatever it ends up
being the other possibility is that he
could be playing Captain fry from the
comics he's another one of Barry's
superiors at the police department who
also has a secret persona called Captain
incredible so ship could be playing a
superhero in disguise no matter who his
alter-ego is on the show as for when
episode 1 is officially going to air and
which day of the week the flash is going
to be on we don't know yet but CW is
announcing that officially during their
up fronts on Thursday so whenever they
do announce it I'll just add something
in the description my guess is that
it'll either replace star cross which
was cancelled on Mondays at 8:00 or 9:00
or it will replace the 100 after arrow
on Wednesdays the only reason I'm kind
of hoping that it's on a separate night
from arrow is that it is super hard to
get two videos out for shows on the same
night that's why I haven't been doing a
lot of supernatural videos but because
this is the arrow finale I'm going to
start doing bonus videos for both shows
both arrow and flash next week so be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
feel free to leave me suggestions for
topics and stuff you guys want to talk
about my arrow finale will post in a
couple hours and my Q&A will post
tomorrow like normal I'll be combining
both arrow and flash stuff so feel free
to ask me anything about either show and
I'll include it in the video so right
now you can click here to get my arrow
finale video and you can click here to
get that Q&A I'll add the annotations as
soon as I post the videos thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives
you